je vais commencer là
n'est-ce pas
bonjour je veux que ça n'a je suis
rousseur et c'est moi qui faisait partie
de ma vie lorsque j'habitais en Russie
sont les insultes qui font partie du
quotidien des inconvénients de notre
quotidien nous les entendons presque
tous les jours de la part des Slaves et
des Turcs
pour vous éclairer un peu Turquie
signifie
idiot en russe mais c'est fortement
utilisé contre les Caucasiens alors que
veut dire la croix en Arméniens mais
c'est aussi utilisé comme mon insulte
par des Turcs en raison de leur religion
à mon avis pour comprendre mieux la
situation il faut remonter dans le temps
là où tout a commencé
un événement dont nous parlons pas assez
et qui ont pris le cœur le génocide
arménien qui date de 1915 et qui se
poursuit jusqu'à ce jour mais sous une
autre forme
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous parler
d'une personne très importante à mes
yeux
une personne qui n'a cessé de subir des
réflexions et des agressions en raison
de sa nationalité et cette personne
c'est ma mère
une femme merveilleienne allonger
aujourd'hui une femme me grandeur qui
m'a transmet le message l'importance du
respect aux autres alors que elle elle
avait des difficultés à retrouver un
logement car chaque annonce indiqué que
les biens étaient vendus que au stade
est à qui ont des mauvaises échanger son
nom de famille arménien pour les
conséquences pour un nom de famille plus
gentielle elle qui se faisait juger pour
parler en ayant dans la rue et bien
sachez qu'elle n'a jamais détesté ces
personnes
au début je ne la comprenais pas
pourquoi elle voulait pas se venger de
ces personnes qui lui ont fait du mal
mais au fur et à mesure de mes
expériences personnelles j'ai commencé à
mieux comprendre c'est bien de cela que
j'ai envie de vous parler aujourd'hui de
ce cheminement intérieur de ce passage
de la haine jusqu'au respect aux autres
pendant qu'on enfance en Russie mes
soeurs et moi-même ont subi un
traitement différentiel des autres comme
par exemple à l'école pendant la
récréation les groupes amis ont été
divisés en deux ils étaient basés sur
les nécessité des autres donc il y avait
le groupe D'Amico Casa et cela par les
combinaisons
et les ingénieurs eux-mêmes
nous étions détesté les règles de le
dire mon cœur se sert
la montagne
de la journée
moi j'étais assez chanceuse de ne pas
avoir un physique arménien
mais mes sœurs n'ont pas eu la même
chose
les élèves russes faisaient que son
prendre à leur nez poursu leur peau
foncé leurs cheveux noirs crépus et
leurs bras plus poilu que la moyenne
je m'appelle m'avoir fait des amis
russes qui ont ensuite fini par se
décaler de moi quand ils ont appris que
j'étais à moitié arménienne
au début je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
je n'arrivais pas à me faire des amis
russes en étant à moitié russe moi-même
mais c'est après que ma mère m'a
expliqué que ce monde dit que Mayenne
ont réussi n'était pas bien vu pourtant
moi j'étais fière d'être à moitié
harmonienne jouer c'est ça comme une
richesse mais quand on a déménagé en
France ma mère elle lui roulait de
arrêter de son handicap Marvel pour ne
plus se faire graisser elle avait peur
pour nous
pourtant je trouve ça bizarre car la
Russie contient le plus d'Arméniens en
elle après l'Arménie elle-même mais
c'est là qu'on retrouve le plus
d'agressions envers eux
cela ne concerne pas tous les Russes
quand même parce que
la meilleure amie de ma grande sœur là
et ça est un bel exemple elle s'appelle
la SIA elle est venue cette semaine en
France pour voir un peu le pays mais le
plus important pour voir ma sœur
[Musique]
en tout cas ce n'est pas que les Russes
qui peuvent être aussi gentil avec nous
car les airbags jamais sont aussi très
agréables comme la grande sœur l'air ça
nous racontait quand elle est tombée
malade elle a fini à l'hôpital à Moscou
et ça son ami azerbajanaise a fait tout
jusqu'à ce que se faire passer comme ça
soeur pour venir la voir dans sa chambre
c'est sûr on peut faire paraître banal
mais c'est ça qui me réchauffe le cœur
le plus car ça me donne de l'espoir que
le monde n'est pas arrivé au monde on
pense à table
ça me donne de l'espoir que on peut
encore changer
ma mère me racontait souvent l'histoire
des ses grands-parents
et je pense que c'est un humain
maintenant de transmettre ce message
cette mémoire
sans Go en pair tonneau
âgé de 6 ans
avait deux frères séries qui avait 10
ans et David qui n'avait que trois ans
quand le génocide arménien a commencé
puis c'était les garçons de plus de 10
ans
les électricités se succédaient leur
mère enceinte a été violée et tué dans
les yeux de péché
votre personne avec un bâton
les enfants étaient forcés à insister à
ces scènes atroces car il n'avait pas de
choix
puis les gens ont fini par les
abandonner
mais la Croix-Rouge française les a
retrouvé les a remet au bord du maire
pour les sauver un médecin français
voulait prendre le petit garçon David
qui n'avait que trois ans avec lui
mais tonneau est tombé au pied de ce
médecin on le suppliant de laisser le
petit frère avec eux ils imaginez pas
leur famille c'est pareil en avons déjà
perdu leurs parents
un homme géorgien aime s'aimer
à ce médecin de laisser les trois frères
ensemble c'est ce qu'il a fait
puis les trois frères
c'est comme ça que ma famille se
retrouvait en janvier
pourtant la mer nous interdit de parler
mal des Turcs et des examens
mais pourquoi je vous parle de cela
qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de transmettre
mon message
le message que j'ai envie de transmettre
c'est simple ne pas oublier et pardonner
le génocide arménien est un fait et on
ne peut pas le remonter dans le temps
pour le changer
mais nous avons les préhistoriques et la
mémoire sur nos mains le son des minois
des innocents de pas être écoulés pour
rien et j'en cite vraiment sur ce point
là parce que le passé des Arméniens en
plus beaucoup sur leur présence
et quand je dis qu'il faut aussi savoir
pardonner je parle des tubes
d'aujourd'hui
car les nouvelles générations n'ont rien
fait à mon peuple et même s'il y a des
Turcs encore ce n'est pas la peine de
généraliser
quand je parlais de la vengeance au
début je ne comprenais pas à quel point
ça ne faisait aucun sens
car si on continue à se détester la
haine et les guerres ne s'arrêteront
jamais
comme un arbre ne l'avait raconté dans
un village arménien de son ami le peuple
a voulu se venger ils ont coupé la tête
d'un homme qui concerne azerbagané pour
au final on trouvait qu'il était
arménien
quand ma mère me le dirait la vengeance
n'a pas de merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]